[Music]
hey everybody it's a pleasure to welcome
all my guests on the into the impossible
podcast but none more so than when you
get to interview a friend and a
colleague and today we're really graced
by the presence of Navon professor
abigail lira gaby as I call her of the
University of Chicago Abby how are you
doing in Chicago currently I'm doing
fine in Chicago we you know like
everybody else who can we're staying
home these days and trying to get some
work done it's actually kind of a fun
time because it means that we get to
embark on a few kind of crazier projects
with my grad students while we can't get
into the lab yeah today's theme will be
nothing if not crazy I do want to point
out Abby's a professor associate
professor right your associate professor
of physics and astronomy do you have a
courtesy appointment no it's just
physics actually just physics okay yeah
purists that's phenomenal and he is a
recent winner of the presidential early
career award for scientists and
engineers and congratulations is a
storied cohort and extending yourself
that that's true that's right well in
the timer verse sense you paved the way
for people like me I understand you were
heartbroken that you didn't get to meet
President Trump is that correct
completely I do have a signature on the
piece of paper so as I have george w
bush's signature i actually got to meet
him so that was that was a nice well
today's event well first of all should
say that I know you for more than 10
years I've tried unsuccessfully on many
occasions to get to get you to come to
San Diego as a postdoc as a professor
luckily if I had to be beaten out by any
institution it's the University of
Chicago and I'm just so glad that we
continued to work together so it's an a
so it's a great pleasure to to talk to
all the scientists who come on the show
and lately we've
a lot of theorists on the show and more
than that it's not enough to just have
theorists we've had theorists that are
proposing truly groundbreaking of true
ideas and notions about new paradigm
shifts for the way the universe is
organized and one of those might
intersect or might not I'm speaking
about Eric Weinstein's theory of
geometric unity which some have said
might predict even the existence of
particles that don't fit into the
standard model either have weird spin
properties or anti particles that have
unusual properties but there's a
potential you know relevance to that
project that you worked on for your PhD
thesis and continuing to work on called
Anita and Anita stands for why you tell
me what does it need a stand for first
of all it's the Antarctic impulsive
transient antenna and we borrow the end
from Antarctic like any good acronym it
doesn't quite fit but it's Antarctic
impulsive transient antenna yeah so for
those of you watching the video behind
us is really the reason that we met that
Abby and I met and that's the bicep2
experiment which is located in
Antarctica at the center of Antarctica
at the South Pole and bicep2 brought us
together first of all back when we began
our interactions but you had been
working in Antarctica for many years
before that so can you first tell us a
little bit about your experience on
Anita what was it that you actually did
where were you you're working in UCLA
over fellow Californian can you tell us
more about what it's like to do that
work and what your thesis project was
all about yeah so I've been working on
Anita I guess for 15 years which seems
kind of crazy when you put it that way
I should have yeah so I I should have
sent some pictures of sort of the fun
pictures of like the old times on Anita
because it's fun to think back to
graduate school but my thesis was the
search for neutrinos with Anita from the
second flight so just to put that in
context Anita at this point I need is a
NASA long-duration balloon experiment
and Bryan has flipped to a picture of
Anita it's on the far right is
here's the closeup of it yeah and then
it's a balloon experiment so you attach
a payload like that that weighs a few
thousand pounds to basically the end of
a huge helium balloon and the balloon
doesn't look that big in this picture
actually because when it's on the ground
it is only inflated that much but then
when you launch it you know into the
upper upper atmosphere it becomes the
size of a football stadium so it's a
huge helium balloon capable of lifting
many thousand pounds to about 40
kilometers above the earth hmm and then
you know you you build whatever
instrument you want to put it on this
balloon and then it circles around
Antarctica and most people use this
platform to look up at the sky to look
for various kinds of radiation that you
can't see from the ground because the
atmosphere gets in the way but what we
do is we use this platform to get really
high above Antarctica to actually look
down at the ice for neutrinos
interacting in the ice that then give
off a radio signal that we look for in
the balloon with the payload and we do
this because we want to see a huge
volume of ice all at once because the
particles are so rare that you need to
monitor a very large volume to have any
prayer of seeing anything so at this
point Anita has had four flights I was a
graduate student on the second flight of
Anita that was my first trip to
Antarctica in 2008 and you know my
thesis result was the main result from
that experiment since then of course
I've worked on the third and fourth
flight of Anita as well and I also was
on the first flight I was just a junior
graduate student though so it wasn't my
thesis and yeah we are still doing
analysis of the data from later flights
my group I have a postdoc and a student
who are still you know partly working on
this the data from this experiment was
there an upcoming flight that's planned
so there's no upcoming flight of Anita
that's planned but we did propose an
experiment that would be sort of the
fall
to Anita and basically what's happened
in the last five or so years is we've
had a little bit of a technology
breakthrough that has allowed us to
build a much more sensitive instrument
so we think we can design an instrument
that's about a factor of 10 more
sensitive than Anita so we've proposed
that and it's called pou AO which is a
funny name for an experiment the reason
we picked that name is because the
University of Hawaii has always been a
major part of this project in Puyo is a
the name of a Hawaiian bird a native
Hawaiian bird and it also fits the
acronym well okay I'll be interested to
see that replace the the penguin has the
official bird of Antarctica be probably
cruel to bring it to Antarctica from
Hawaii so our listeners are probably you
know familiar with exotic phenomenon
we've had on Barry parish from LIGO
talking about interesting phenomena in
the gravitational wave sector and we've
had on many people talking about the
Cosmic Microwave Background and the in
the looking for signatures of new
physics or old physics in the Cosmic
Microwave Background an ancient photon
sector neutrinos are different what what
exactly is a neutrino what's a proper
way to think about neutrinos and are all
neutrinos you know equally good to
reveal new physics the way that all
photons are I would say photons are like
commodities you seen one you seen all
our neutrinos of the different types are
they equally good at possibly revealing
new physics that you might hope to
expect to see yeah so first I guess
there were a few questions in there but
the first I'll answer is what is a
neutrino I guess I there's many ways to
think about a neutrino I mean it's like
definition a neutrino is a fundamental
particle which means that it can't be
broken down into smaller pieces just
like an electron or a photon you know
it's something that we think is sort of
like a basic building block of matter a
neutrino is a cousin to an electron it's
in the same family of particles it has
similar interactions as an electron
which is just like an electron is the
electrons are everywhere there
coal's that are in Adams right but a
neutrino you never trust them because
they make up everything that's right but
a neutrino doesn't have charge so the
thing that's weird is if you imagine an
electron and then you like have an
electron with no charge the way an
electron interacts with everything is it
interacts electromagnetically it
interacts because it has charge like
it's you know attracted to other stuff
but the neutrino it's like the weird
cousin of an electron that doesn't have
charge and so then you're like well what
the heck how is it gonna interact with
it how do we know it exists right to
know something's exist you kind of has
to interact or something for you to see
it so it turns out that there's another
sort of fundamental force called the
weak force that is aptly named because
it is much weaker than the other forces
and that's how neutrinos interact so
they don't interact very often and
that's why people call them like if you
people use the flashy word like a ghost
particle right which is kind of a funny
word but why do they use that they use
it because they kind of move through the
universe not interacting very often it's
hard to see them hmm and they're good I
was gonna say so your other major
question was like are all neutrinos the
same for discovery so there's different
kinds of neutrinos they just we think
there's in the fundamental standard
model of particle physics we think
there's three kinds of neutrinos for
some reason things seem to come in
threes in particle physics and we don't
really know why that is but in any case
there seems to be three you know types
of neutrinos for us they're all
basically the same in terms of their
ability to lead to discovery because
what we're trying to do is use neutrinos
as messenger particles to learn about
astrophysics so we want to learn about
what is the physics that's driving the
most you know the the most energetic
things in the universe
what is accelerating the most energetic
particles in the universe
how do you know how do those engines
work and what are those sources what do
they look like so for us all neutrinos
are the same for helping us learn
and so Anita was designed specifically
to look for one of the three flavors as
I understand it the town neutrino is
that correct
so actually neutral was designed so it's
I needed a little bit of a complicated
story so Anita was designed actually to
look for all three flavors of neutrinos
the main way that Anita looks for
neutrinos is a neutrino comes from
somewhere in outer space some very
energetic source in the universe maybe
it's an active galactic nuclei nucleus
which is a black hole in the center of a
galaxy that's accreting matter
maybe that process makes high-energy
particles that's a common theory okay so
let's say a neutrino comes from there
comes to the earth and it hits the
Antarctic ice and makes a part of shower
of particles so a neutrino it's like
billiard balls a neutrino comes in hits
a nucleus in an atom and then it makes
like a splash of stuff and that's a
bunch of particles that splash of stuff
gives off radiation that's what we look
for and and any flavor of neutrino can
do that
and they make pretty similar showers as
far as we as far as our ability to
detect them you know goes if you knew if
you could really detect the fine details
you could tell that the showers would be
slightly different but as far as we care
they all kind of look the same so that's
Anita's main method of discovering
neutrinos turns out there's another
channel for Anita that is only sensitive
to one flavor that's the Tau neutrino
mm-hmm so it's like we have two ways of
looking one is through this channel that
looks for all the different kinds of
neutrinos and then another way of
looking is this channel that's only good
for looking at tau neutrinos and that
just the mechanism is slightly different
for that I see now I'm going to get back
to why those particular chap that
particular channel is so pertinent
perhaps or not to these tantalizing
provocative new conjectures that we've
heard about but for someone talk a
little bit about our shared fondness for
Antarctica and why you would go there
instead of staying in Chicago this is a
live view out your wind
of the yeah Chicago's Lake Michigan
oceanfront it's probably Hawaii but why
why go to the trouble of going down you
know to the bottom of the world
literally great expense and so forth why
go to that great lengths literally to
look for this humble and ghostly
particle yeah so for us it's like it's I
think it's like kismet it's like a
coincidence of many factors that make a
needle possible one is that the the long
duration balloon program exists in
Antarctica like NASA flies payloads over
Antarctica and why do they do it in
Antarctica so this is independent of
Anita so why does NASA fly these big
payloads over Antarctica when you know
they could launch them anywhere the
reason is because in Antarctica in the
summer these winds these winds called
the circumpolar winds so in the upper
atmosphere these winds set up that mean
that when you when you launch a balloon
it just gets swept away in a circle
around the pole and it allows you to
just keep rotating around Antarctica and
then eventually when you get back to
where you came from you can cut your
payload down and recover it near where
you started and that's unique in the
world like you can't I guess you could
do that in the northern hemisphere but
it's difficult to do that because
there's not land everywhere near the
pole in the northern hemisphere so
that's why the balloon program exists in
Antartica in the first place is because
if you want to launch a big payload on a
balloon and do any science with it and
have it up for 30 or 40 days that's a
good place to do it in other places in
the world you'd have to cut the payload
down after a day or two because it would
drift too far away so then Anita is a
funny thing because it takes advantage
of that but it also takes advantage of
the fact that that's happening over you
know a nut sheet that's a few kilometers
thick and what we use is art that's two
things that like work together in favor
the balloon program the winds and
erricka work in our favor and then the
thick ice sheet and then the third that
really works in our favor is that
Antarctica is also a very quiet place to
work in there's not a lot of noise
so when you launch you're very sensitive
detector you actually have a chance to
see physics rather than just like
man-made radio interference although hmm
and so as this would it be fair to say
that IceCube is a similar experiment or
is it more of a competitor or they
sensitive to similar effects such as the
one that prompted this discussion yeah
so IceCube is a little bit different of
an experiment it's a complementary
experiment our ice cube looks at a
little bit lower energy neutrinos and we
look for a little bit higher energy
neutrinos and there actually isn't that
much overlap between the two techniques
and you can think about it this way so
Anita is really high above the ice and
it looks at a lot of ice that's pretty
far away from the payload whereas Ice
Cube is a detector at the South Pole
that has a bunch of detectors right in
the ice and so what they're doing is
looking at a smaller piece of ice but
they're looking at it much more close up
and so that just allows you to see
smaller signals it allows you to see you
know smaller particle showers which
means you can see lower energy nutrients
so Ice Cube is really geared for a
little bit lower energy and Anita is
really geared for the highest energies
there is some overlap but it's pretty
complementary really having been to both
environments both the South Pole and the
coast of Antarctica McMurdo where these
where these balloons are launched from
so can you talk a little bit about what
it's like to get there I showed the
plane let's see
the c-17 that takes you down if you're
lucky sometimes you get a c-130 and
that's not so lucky can you talk a
little bit about what it's like to be
there and a graduate student days and
then come back as a professor or you
know senior leader in the field what
what's it like at these two different
environments and I didn't see too many
people with purple you know leisure
suits and blue hair at the South Pole it
seems a lot more business-focused
serious but what's it what's how do you
compare the two difference
for those of our audience who haven't
been there yes I've been obviously to
both McMurdo Station which is on the
coast of Antarctica and South Pole so
McMurdo Station is where the balloons
launch run it's um you know it's warmer
there so in the summer it's actually
pretty bright and sunny all day and it's
you know 20 degrees Fahrenheit and so
it's actually kind of nice as you can
see this is a picture of New Year's Eve
that's midnight on New Year's Eve and
you know we're all outside having a good
time and you can see it's not actually
that cold out on January 1st which is
the height of summer of course if you
were outside at the height of summer
that's a pole it would still be minus 20
or something like that and that would be
pretty pretty cool to be doing something
like this you know life in Antarctica is
it's pretty fun I think sometimes I
think about it's kind of like college
like you're in a dorm
you've got shared shared cafeteria you
see the same people over and over
oh sorry Brian Acadia I'm sorry if you
go to like a college inside of a strip
mine you know it's also very industrial
at McMurdo but yeah I like it better
than the South Paul I don't know why
people like the South open McMurdo's
have fun there's about a thousand people
there most of the people there are not
scientists most of the people there are
really hard-working people who are
making science happen by supporting the
station and supporting the scientists to
do you know to to get the science done
and yeah I don't know life in Antarctica
is pretty fun I will say you know
something Brian said made me remember
you know life in Antarctica as a
graduate student is very different than
life now in Antarctica now like when I
was a graduate student that's yeah
that's a picture of the cafeteria on
Thanksgiving you can see someone's
wearing a tie that's like you know
that's Thanksgiving in the cafeteria but
life life as a graduate student in
Antarctica was like pretty carefree in
the sense that you could turn off
everything else in the outside world and
pretend you had no internet even though
you really do have internet and and just
be you can just be with your experiment
like you
and just wake up every morning someone
cooks breakfast for you
then you go to work all day and someone
cooks lunch for you and then you go home
and you don't have to worry about like
paying bills or commuting or it just is
you're just you're just working on your
work in that was it's just that was
great really yeah would you pay for that
right how much did you pay for that you
bring your money but now as a professor
when I go just been to South Pole in the
last few years it's very different
because like you still have this whole
other job that you have to do at home
and you spend all day doing that same
thing working on your experiment but
then the flips the switch flips and at
night then you have to do your other job
that's still at home so it's it's much
more stressful to be in Antartica now
yeah yeah I can imagine well thanks for
that that's a very interesting insight
into the difference between these
different phases and you know most of
the general public if they know a
scientist at all or know somebody who's
in physics would just know what we do
from the Big Bang Theory and it's a fun
show and actually your advisor a former
adviser as a graduate student had some
involvement that show right yeah my my
PhD adviser is David Salzburg and he's
the scientist the scientific consultant
for the Big Bang Theory and then I think
he's also doing young Sheldon that's
sort of follow-on show I say okay yeah
so I mean that's obviously there's a lot
of artistic license that takes place
there but you know it is very different
you don't really see both the you know
the really good aspects as Abby just
mentioned as you mentioned but also you
know the challenges in different levels
of being a scientist and and really the
stakes rise and continue to only
continue arises you're doing more and
more research and getting to know
different heights literally in the case
of Edina so getting back to there too
the reason for our conversation then
today was this very provocative report
which I first saw in the most gust of
all scientific journals called the New
York Post and I pointed out that you
know what they say about nature magazine
could probably apply for the New York
Post
not everything just because it's
published in the New York Post doesn't
necessarily mean it's wrong but but they
have some pretty outlandish statements
in there and even included some from the
principal investigator on this project
Peter Gorham and I wonder if first can
you take us through what is a principal
investigator is that a principal you
know from high school who you know turns
into a private investigator in a variety
of different ways but in this way it
means that Peter is the sort of head of
the project he's like there's a you know
seven or eight institutions each with
faculty working on this project and
Peter is the one who ultimately is the
Gateway to talk to NASA about the
project right like so he's the one who
is sort of ultimately in charge that to
make sure that the mission succeeds and
we do our science and you know all of
that so that the P I responsible is you
know a little bit more than the other
faculty I'll say especially in NASA NASA
is a little bit of a right I mean
different government agencies put a
little more or less weight on the PI
status but you know yeah so that's I
guess what a PI is it's sort of of the
professor's working on the project he's
the professor who is the the lead the
one that people would talk to and the
one who is ultimately sort of the
connection with NASA
mm-hm so what he's quoted as saying in
this article and others really revolves
around the behavior of these poltergeist
particles called neutrinos which I
always like to point out they're really
the only form of dark matter that we
know exists I mean they have mass and
they and weakly interact they don't
interact with photons and yet they do
have an ability to exhibit some sort of
bizarre behavior when they pass through
matter we won't get into the exact
effect that you're searching for is very
technical we'll have some links to that
but they you know kind of a headline
that's printed you know at least
and things like New York Post and others
is that because of the way of his
particles interact so so inefficiently
these town a tree knows that the only
way they could be detected is if the
neutrino changed into a different type
of particle before passing through the
earth and back again and he's quoted as
saying that there's this phenomenon that
could explain this and that somehow and
we don't exactly understand even as
experts in the field how this implies
the existence of an of an parallel
universe let alone the multiverse but
can you say something about how the town
neutrinos assuming that theories that
this effect is you know borne out and is
verifiable which which you can also
comment on I mean your confidence in
this result not the interpretation but
how confident are you and say the data
themselves and what other sorts of
phenomena could explain the results but
not be so sensationalized yeah so I
think there's a lot wrapped up here one
so I always I'm an experimentalist which
you know and so I'll always I'll answer
the question about the data first which
is I can tell you what we saw so Anita
was designed to look for high-energy
neutrinos and what that really means is
Anita is an extremely sensitive radio
detector that looks for little blips of
radio waves and we when we think we see
something interesting we record it and
we look at the data later and analyze
the data
okay so there's other things that could
make radio blips other than neutrinos
and that's called background so this is
common in like particle physics
experiments you see some number of
events interesting time frames in our in
our case and you're trying to like sift
through those interesting time frames to
see if there's any neutrinos in there or
any other interesting physics and you're
trying to sift through what other you
know there may be other things that kind
of mimic that signal that would be
really boring so one example is in our
case for Anita is man-made backgrounds
meaning like people at McMurdo Station
right you turn on your snowmobile and it
makes
radio blip so that's a you know problem
for us we can try to measure that and
there's lots of ways to sort of
characterize the signals that we think
we can basically distinguish the signal
from a neutrino from other things but
it's not a perfect discriminator you can
never build a perfect discriminator so
what this means is that at the end of
the day you're left with some background
we call it you're left with some you
know estimate of what what sort of the
noise might be left in you're left in
your analysis so we did an analysis
looking for looking for showers made by
both cosmic rays which are protons
mostly that make showers in the
atmosphere and Anita sees a bunch of
those cosmic rays it's a you know it's
not like an exciting new discovery but
we do see cosmic rays because they're
coming at us all the time and another
type of particle that might make a
shower like that as a town neutrino so
it but the difference would be that a
cosmic ray of course is coming from
above and it would make a shower and
then the radio waves from that shower
actually for Anita actually reflect off
of the ice and then come back up to
Anita so it's kind of a funny geometry
problem where Anita's so high above the
atmosphere that we actually don't see
cosmic rays above us we see we see the
reflected radio waves off of the ice
it's like the ice is a mirror you know
and the radio waves come back up we also
could see a Tau neutrino which could
come through the earth interact in the
ice make another particle called a tau
leptons which is a charged particle that
then makes a similar signal so basically
a Tau neutrino could ultimately make a
very similar signal to a cosmic ray air
shower except for the fact that that
that shower is coming up through the
earth and because it's coming up through
the earth the radio waves don't have to
reflect off the ice to get back to us so
the the signal the thing that's kind of
subtle is that we see a bunch of cosmic
rays with a signal that we can you know
we we've seen like tens of them they all
look very similar and then we see these
few events there's two events that look
of air
much like a cosmic ray except they're
flipped upside down so you ask like how
did they get flipped upside down and the
data
well they got flipped upside down
because the cosmic rays reflected off
the mirror and when they reflected off
the mirror they got flipped but these up
going tau neutrinos those signals didn't
get flipped so it's like that's how
ultimately we're doing the
distinguishing between this or what I
would argue is relatively boring cosmic
rays although some people really was are
interesting and and this much more
interesting neutrino signal it's a
subtle thing we're like it's just
because of the way the geometry all
works one of the the cosmic ray events
should look flipped compared to the
neutrinos so we saw two events that had
the opposite flipping from all the
cosmic rays that we saw and the question
is like how does that happen
how does it you know is it you know you
see two events like that and you ask
yourself like well the first question an
experimentalist asks what's the first
question experimentalist ask Brian
what's wrong and so and and the
different ways to phrase that is what
are the other backgrounds so the other
backgrounds are some man-made noise well
we try hard to characterize that we
think we have like a good estimate and
this is still you know three or four
sigma above that and then the other
background could be that maybe there's
some weird thing with the ice where like
when you reflect these cosmic ray
signals maybe they don't actually flip
for some reason maybe there's some weird
interference happening at the surface
that makes it sort of look as if it you
know didn't flip and that would be a
background so that some of these
backgrounds are really hard to estimate
as you can imagine it's really hard to
like make a good guess as to what those
backgrounds are but we've done quite a
bit of simulation and we think it's hard
to explain these events with backgrounds
like that so there's two events left and
then you know you're an experimentalist
and you've got this data and you have
and then you do your what you think is
your due diligence on what else could it
be
background wise and then you publish the
data so then you say like well this is
what we saw we saw two events on a
relatively small background and we don't
know what they are okay so that's that's
fine I think that's the way science
works like you can't sit on your data
forever just because you don't like the
answer right just because you wish it
would go away and I've you know I've
seen that before and we won't say
anything outlandish about it we'll just
say that we don't know what it is so
then the story continues right so then
the first sort of set of so then what
happens in science after that an
experiment puts out this result it says
we saw two of these events that look
like high-energy particles that came
through the earth we don't really know
what they are and we don't know if it's
real or not
because but here's our background
estimate and it looks hard to explain
okay so then a set of theorists come
along and the first set of theorists
points out what is frankly pretty
obvious and that's that the the way that
we the distribution of what these two
events looks like is actually pretty
inconsistent with neutrinos which is
kind of a weird thing like they come
through like the whole earth they are
really steeply up going to Anita and
neutrinos even though there are these
ghost particles that we think don't
enter you know they don't interact very
often at these really high energies they
actually should get absorbed in the
earth so to have something that comes so
steeply up going through the earth
without also seeing a bunch of stuff
coming really shallow is very unlikely
for a regular standard model neutrino so
that's sort of the first set of papers
that came out after we published our
data and like we should say that the
data were published what in 2018 2020 60
26 yeah 2016 might have been the first
paper and then there was a second paper
in 2018 right okay yeah so yeah so the
first setting theorist came out and and
said an important statement which is
these don't really look like tau
neutrinos you know weak
I've already knew that but I feel like
our job as experimentalist is to stay
true to the data and try not to push the
hype right because if we as an
experiment came out and said hey this is
you know whatever no you know for
something Sigma above background and it
doesn't look like a town neutrino then
all of a sudden you've upped again
you've upped the pipe right because then
the following question is well what is
it right and this sparked actually a
fair number of groups to say like oh let
me try out my somewhat more crazy -
somewhat less crazy Theory ideas on a
fun side project I think a lot of people
did this there were a bunch of theory
papers about supersymmetric particles
called staus you know maybe it could be
some supersymmetric particle maybe it
could be some Dark Matter particle maybe
it could be you know whatever there's a
stairwell neutrinos like there's a
variety of you know more or less out
there ideas of what it could be and that
comes from sort of independent theory
groups over the last few years yeah okay
so then that like you know makes people
within the field they're kind of having
fun I would say and saying like Oh
wouldn't it be great if this was real
but I mean you know it's two events and
the experimentalist aren't jumping up
and down about it so that probably means
we shouldn't jump up and down about it
but we're still gonna write our theory
papers because that's fun and that cycle
I want to get into and in a bit but you
know they'll take one quote and then it
seems to have go on a life of its own
and these papers don't come with Surgeon
General warnings that they you know it's
I always find it and I wonder you know
if you had a similar experience back in
the bicep2 days when we together both
our 50 colleagues bicep2 experiment
published claim detection of
inflationary gravitational waves even
the week before we published I was
getting emails from former professors
and colleagues all theorists that were
saying you know we heard this rumor
and I don't know how that got out
because I know you didn't say anything I
know I didn't say but they were asking
us for you know could it explain you
know this magnetic monopole it could
explain a string yeah you know my theory
is in cot is you know is is completely
in in concert with this and I wonder you
know do you have the set impression I
often feel like theorists because a
theory in some ways is I've comes down
to two different flavors as I often see
it it's either incremental but not in
the bad way it's just adding to the
standard model and understanding
different extensions of it or it's truly
serendipitous and that you really
conjecture there's this new
bose-einstein condensate that could
occur or you know or what have you and
the same is sure an experiment there's
incremental improvement that we make we
built better CMB detectors better neon
detectors and neutrino detectors and it
gets steadily better and then sometimes
you hear a beeping radio noise from
outer space and lo and behold you
discovered pulsars and so I wonder is
there a parallel in your mind between
those two and why does the hype if it if
you do believe it it seems like this
hype as you said it you know kind of
gets amplified despite the efforts of
the experimentalist why do you think
that is I have some ideas but I like to
hear why do you think yeah the hype
comes from the theory side in a certain
sense you know the claim that yes we're
living in a multiverse and not only a
multiverse but time goes backwards and
there's why did that why does that
happen so often in your opinion yeah I
mean it's interesting you bring up
bicep2 and I I think these stories are
actually a little bit different so in
this case the experimentalists we
published our data but with no pomp and
circumstance right it was like you know
here's a PR D which doesn't mean much to
the audience we're like here's a paper
that doesn't even rise to the level of
like a fancy fancy journal it's just
like an OK journal we're gonna put it in
right because we didn't think it was you
know that flashy right and we didn't put
out a press release and yes we talked
about it at conferences but it's like
you know here these two events here's
the background and then we just leave it
at that like we don't know what it is
here's what a few theorists have
interpreted isn't that great right but I
think so I think in this case
some of the hype has been driven a
little bit by theorists but I don't
think that that they've been intending
to drive hype I think that's just partly
the role of theory I think partly the
role of theory is to look at what could
be an interesting result and come up
with ways to explain it right and so
that's what the people who wrote this
paper about the the thing that
ultimately led to parallel universes
with the time running backwards the the
person who wrote it Lois Sanger dokie is
a very well-respected theorist and he's
just you know writing something fun you
know something interesting down for the
scientific community about what it is
right and he wrote that paper last year
I mean it's not like it happened this
spring right and so then then a science
news outlet called New Scientist wrote
an actually a pretty good article about
his theory paper as well as a few other
theory papers and interviewed the PI of
a neat appeared or Graham and you know
it was a pretty II even-handed I think
coverage of the sort of interesting
thing like hey they've got these events
we don't really know what they are it
could be background but here's some
interesting theories and then the New
York Post and others just pick the
headline up right and all of a sudden
it's NASA scientists claim they've Carol
you know which NASA scientists never
claimed this right of parallel universe
with time running backwards so I do
think that it's partly the role of
theorists to look at experimental
results and try to do some
interpretation mm-hmm I think that this
story for Anita is a bit different than
by - by said - and I can see this as
someone who was on the experiment was a
little more driven by the
experimentalists right it was hey we
built this experiment to measure
gravitational waves from inflation and
at least the press release said we think
we did it you know the paper was the
paper the scientific paper was much more
even-handed about what the results were
they just said you know we saw in excess
City no which is drink we saw an excess
signal but the
press-release definitely said you know
and you know first direct evidence yeah
first direct evidence and and that
particular result was the the pomp and
circumstance around that result was
driven by the experimentalists for sure
so that's a little bit of a different
situation yes you you know may know I
know you've read the book that I wrote
about this that I view serendipity as
sort of an interesting maybe an assayer
you know type type substance that can
really separate out science that is
perhaps more subject to confirmation
bias the peril of looking for something
I always get asked well what did you
hope to discover and you know those are
phrases that we of course think about I
mean we wouldn't be human beings we
didn't think about it and contrary to
stereotypes we are human beings that can
test us
Abbie's humanity and graciousness but
the but the fact is that you know
headlines
you know usually are driven by you know
kind of serendipitous discoveries in the
sense that you really weren't expecting
and and yet it's almost the opposite
like the public will pay more attention
to something serendipitous if it has an
interesting explanation which may or not
be blessed by the by the authors of the
of the data themselves so just to close
up I want to talk about you know your
philosophy of science and that you know
you mentioned that it's not you are
building a successor to that experiment
in a sense but but the question of how
and when to turn off an experiment has
always been interesting to me in other
words bicep ora Simon's Observatory or
something's right we could observe for
many years and not see anything at
quote-unquote you know and that we
wouldn't have seen the evidence for the
thing that we were seeking similarly you
know the Higgs boson did you know
detection has been claimed as the main
output of LHC but it's not been turned
off yet and people are trying to
speculate on what it would take to build
a bigger better experiment what do you
think it is really you know kind of the
ultimate point as a you know as a leader
in the field how do you feel you come to
a decision let's terminate this
experiment let's look to design another
one because you've created new
experiments and new ideas how does that
work is that creative activity
so two-part question how do you know
when to shut off an experiment I pull
the plug you know to use a crude analogy
and - what how do you think of these
ideas for new techniques and your
approach as an experimentalist yeah so I
think the question of when to shut up an
experiment is really hard as you just
said like it's really hard I think to me
that's where you have to I always try to
retreat to the science questions right
because that's what we're altom utley
doing or ultimately trying to answer
science questions so I do think it has
to be driven by the science and what I
mean by that is I think there's at least
two kinds of science but there's two
kinds of science one is where you're
kind of looking for a particular
signature of a theory that someone or
multiple people have written down in
multiple ways like it's kind of like
looking for something that you know what
you're looking for because a bunch of
theorists think it's interesting to go
there and that's where you go and I
think that's where it when it's
important to have good you know good
theory colleagues it's like there's
people whose job whose job it is and
that they spend their lives helping
experimentalist try to figure out where
to go next right
you shouldn't so one could argue that
you shouldn't build or run an experiment
if if a bunch of people agree that
there's nothing to see there right like
if if you get a factor of two more data
is there nothing to see there and if you
know all your theory colleagues that you
trust are telling you no you have to
think hard about making the decision to
go forward anyone right I mean or try to
go forward but the other kind of science
I think there is a little bit of this
like unknown right sometimes you just
stumble across it Sarah look at us you
stumble across something that like no
one thought would be there so I don't
ever want to become someone who only
looks where people tell me to look
because because I think in some ways
like the great discoveries will also be
made by looking in places that you know
that people think are crazy right it's
on some level there's kind of you know
on some level
you only ever looked where people told
you told you to look what fun would that
be so right so if you have an experiment
that's running you know like Anita has
had four flights and we can ask the
question should we fly a fifth flight of
Anita and I actually think the answer to
that is probably not with the same
instrument and that's because you know
the first flight is a bit when Anita one
flew it was kind of groundbreaking right
there was nobody else who had designed
any experiment like that who could look
at the highest energy neutrinos it was
just like this open field for all we
knew there was you know super heavy dark
matter decaying and giving us tons of
neutrinos there and like we could have
made a great discovery with anyone but a
lot of those models you know have been
ruled out it's like I need a success
right yeah yeah exactly so I needed to
is a little better and either threes a
little better and you combine and
eventually you sort of say like well is
another 50% worth it or something and
eventually you kind of like maybe it's
because I'm used to looking at plots on
a log scale where like you know where
where I always think in factors of 10
rather than an adding I always think
like can I get a factor of whatever
rather than can I add a little bit of
sensitivity and you know at some point
you have to sit back and redesign your
experiment so that's the question I
think about when to turn it off and
partly that has to be guided by
theorists I think of when do you when do
you say like enough is enough if there's
no interesting model right below where
you are why would you keep running the
question of technology development is
another one that you asked yeah how do
you create these ideas is it like an art
is it just inspiration strikes you so
that that's the part that I like to do
and it seems like it usually comes in
the middle of the night for me like its
ear or its you know at some random time
of the day I'll be walking outside like
basically I spent the first I mean I
guess I've been a professor for seven
years or something and I spent the first
five or sixty of those years developing
more
or less one idea so it was one idea to
build better technology for experiments
like Anita and experiments that are sort
of the ground-based version of Anita
that we're actually sending to Greenland
this summer fingers crossed
in a few months all a bunch of hardware
should leave our the front door of our
lab but I basically spent the first six
years developing one technology
advancement and that's because it was a
good one
and you know you you go through like ten
ideas or a hundred ideas that are only
okay or frankly bad and then you come up
with like one good idea and it turns out
that you know then and if it's feasible
and it works then it can change the
field and you know it's not like it's
gonna be some major revolution that's
gonna totally you know change our
understanding of the universe but at
least not right away but it is you know
this new sort of electronic system will
get us a factor of 10 improvement on
Anita and it will you know I hope and
think it's probably going to be the case
that it'll be the sort of heart of the
next generation of ice cube actually
mm-hm so so yeah I mean you start with
the technology advancement and then see
what happens if you're just down the
road once you've done it so it's
fascinating when I think about the fact
that you have been involved in two
different projects which independently
not through your own doing have claimed
at one point or another been led to the
claim that we live in a multiverse first
with first with with with bicep2 of
course discovering you know what we
thought were dirt was direct evidence
for inflation which has as a concomitant
companion the existence of the
multiverse in many people's estimations
and now with with Anita so I think
you're the only person in that Venn
diagram who sits at the understand so I
want to ask you a question that I ask
all my guests and that's if you could go
back in time what sorts of events would
you are what sorts of advice would you
give to the younger version
and the reason I do this is the name of
our podcast is the arthur c-- clark
center for human imaginations into the
impossible podcast and i don't know if
you're an arthur c clarke fan but he had
many laws his first law that you
probably heard is any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic
you might have heard that but his second
law is the only way to find out what is
possible is to venture beyond a bit and
go into the impossible so i want you to
talk to the 20 year old abby you know
kind of before the arc of your life took
its shape that it has now but things
seemed impossible to you back then that
now by virtue of your going into the
impossible now make perfect sense well I
think it's actually scientifically it's
an easy question to answer that when I
started graduate school on Anita new
Astrophysical neutrinos hadn't been
discovered yet so no one had seen a
neutrino from anywhere in the universe
except from the Sun or well supernova
1987a but from any other source like no
one had seen anything and that happened
for the first time in 2013 and the other
thing that has happened since I started
graduate school was is the discovery of
gravitational waves so in this
particular field where we're looking for
high-energy phenomena in the universe
and trying to characterize what is
happening inside of high energy sources
when I started in the field there was no
field like there was no multi messenger
astronomy like it wasn't a thing because
there was no multi messenger there was
no nutrient there were no neutrinos that
had been discovered there were no
gravitational waves and now it's like I
really think in the next 10 years it's
just going to accelerate and more and
more is going to be possible so that's
kind of an easy question scientifically
of like I I did not when I entered the
field that really was very different
than it is now in terms of what is
possible to do and that is in large part
due to major breakthroughs from very
large experiments right like LIGO and I
cube both very large experiments I think
personally like on the what do you you
know I actually do a lot as you as you
know Brian because your faculty also you
do a lot of talking to the younger
version of yourself don't you like when
you talk to your students yeah I mean
not all of them are the younger version
of you but a lot of the times when I
talk to my students I'm telling them
things that I wish I had heard yeah it
makes me think about being a parent you
know cuz exactly the same way as I'm
sure you've experienced you'll say
things do daughter I'll say things yeah
but I think you know what I would
probably tell my 20 year old self is I
spent too much time worrying about what
other people thought and I think that's
just in general that's probably human
nature but like you know in graduate
school and in early days of scientific
you know development what you want to do
is develop your technical expertise
first I think and also at the same time
like keep in mind the creativity because
you're gonna need that later like once
you're faculty you're gonna need to be
able to dream up all these experiments
and go do them but I think early on I
spent too long trying to sort of please
other people in and in like my mentors
and stuff and if I just sort of gone off
and like did my own thing and just I
think I it would have been a faster sort
of or more rewarding path through I
definitely do that much more now I did
it's like do you know the things that I
find interesting yeah I think that's
really great advice you know out looking
at things and one of our one of my
favorite podcasters is a guy named James
all teacher and he speaks about this as
kind of choosing yourself where you
really can decide for yourself to be
your own mentor or you could be your own
you can live to impress yourself in
other words we spend so much time as
academics and I'm gonna go on his show
in a few weeks
and one of the things I'm gonna talk to
him about is well academia
you really can't choose yourself like
it's not possible you can really have a
side hustle you know let me just design
this hundred billion dollar experiment
in my side you know it's not the same as
you know starting a gourmet soap come I
don't know what people do for science
but the point is it's harder in academia
you can't choose yourself to go to
comrade school you can't choose yourself
to go to college you can't choose
yourself to get a postdoc you can't
choose a grant to get you can't choose a
faculty you know it's like all these
things and all along the way are these
gatekeepers and no matter how high you
get and the you know and and you're
still we still experience that you and I
as Dan your faculty right so existing as
you say int with the comfort of that
milieu but knowing as you have developed
a brand like I look at you and I say you
have a brand that I associate with a B
and and you know there might be some
brand you know tarnished as it is that
people associate with me or something
but that's what I remember meeting you
for the first time and you really kind
of brought that up and in terms of you
know the graduate student brand is to do
something that the other people can't do
on the project and to play that
essential role and remain essential in
it and I see that you continue that and
and your students are lucky to learn
from a mentor like you so I want to
thank you very much for journeying into
the impossible with me today and I know
you're very busy at home and at work and
taking the time out of quarantine and I
hope that were together under future
circumstances that are allow us to be
actually in person so before we go no
can you tell people where to find you on
the web
I'm gonna post a link to your blog not
because it's you know super up-to-date
as you know but because it gives an
insight into what it really feels like
to be an experimental scientist as a be
is and working at the frontiers of human
knowledge and besides the blog which
I'll post is there and your website is
there anything else that you would like
the audience to know about or where to
get in touch with you or find you I mean
I think that I think my website has I
has contact information for me but you
can always write me my UChicago emails
the best way okay great so well
professor University of Chicago
Department of Physics
it's a pleasure to see you it was fun to
have kind of a conversation with you I
feel like this is like a virtual beer I
know I was thinking about it in the last
plane God on was actually to go to San
Diego in like October and I say that's
right the last time I've traveled I know
cuz I had a you had a baby and then this
it so there you go I haven't traveled to
ten I know in some ways that's good but
anyway we won't tell our bosses about
that Abby thank you so much have a
wonderful day